first thing is slope is basically you
know the inclination of a line like how
steep it is or how non steep it is
whether it's positive like it's going up
to the right it's increasing or it's
negative it's going down to the right
it's decreasing zero slope is a
horizontal line and vertical line is an
undefined slope so you can see slope is
defined as the rise so the vertical
change okay over the run which is the
horizontal like the left and right
change sometimes written as Delta Y over
Delta X okay or you can use the formula
y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 when you
subtract the Y's that gives you the
vertical change up and down divided by
the X's that gives you the horizontal
change left and right sometimes students
make a little mistake so be careful here
they'll put those X's in the numerator
and the Y's in the denominator make sure
you don't do that because the Y's
control the rise you want that in the
numerator and the run the X's in the
denominator so let's look at some
examples so there's a couple different
ways to do this one way is just to count
the rise in the run so let's say we
wanted to find the slope of this line
right here okay one way to do it is we
can just count we can say what we're
going down three okay minus 3 and we're
going right to that's positive two so
down is negative up is positive right is
positive left is negative kind of like
think of the number line that'll help
you and so basically here are the slope
is you can see we went down three that's
the rise we want run to that's positive
two so our slope is negative three
halves now if we want to use the formula
think of this as point number one x1 y1
think of this as point number two x2 y2
so what we're going to do is we're going
to subtract the Y so I'm going to do
let's do this way we'll do a zero minus
three okay the order is important so 0
minus 3 y2 minus y1 and then X 2 minus X
1 so 3 minus 1 so that gives us negative
3 over 2 and you can see we get the
exact same slope now what you don't want
to do L just make a note here is that
you don't want to do y 2 minus y
and then x1 minus x2 see how we switched
up the order like Midway you want to
stay consistent you can do 3 minus 0 and
then 1 minus 3 or like we did we did 0
minus 3 and then 3 minus 1 so we're
taking 0.2 minus 0.1 but you could flip
it and do it the opposite way 1.1 minus
0.2 you just don't want to mix and match
okay so let's look at another example
let's say we want to find the slope from
this point to this point let's draw that
like so ok slope that line we can tell
it's positive because going up to the
right just like when you read a book
from left to right in English okay so we
can think of as increasing going up as X
is increasing Y is increasing okay so
here we have a rise 1 2 3 and the run 1
2 3 so we're going up 3 and we're going
right 3 3 divided by 3 is 1 so this has
a slope of positive 1 now if we want to
use the formula the y2 minus y1 over x2
minus x1 we're going to do let's do this
point minus this point so we'll do 3
minus 0 over 1 minus negative 2 okay
when you subtract subtraction is like
adding the opposite so this comes out to
3 3 minus 0 is 3 3 over 3 is 1 we get a
slope of 1 ok let's do another example
now let's say we had a point let's just
say it's right here and another point
right here and we want to look at the
slope of that line well ok this point is
negative 2 0 this actually I'm sorry
this point here is negative 3 0 and this
point here is negative 3 negative 2 ok
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do Y minus y X minus X so 0 minus
negative 2 and negative 3 minus negative
3 now look what we have here we've got
positive 2 over 0 when 0 sin denominator
can't divide by 0 so that means this is
undefined
you draw 0 with a line through
you write the word undefined it means
this is a vertical line okay if it was
the other way if it was zero over two
when zeros in the numerator and
something besides zeros in the
denominator then it's a zero slope and
that's a horizontal line so here are
some examples for finding slope again
you can either count the rise over the
run or you can use your slope slope
formula y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 if
you're enjoying these videos you're
learning something subscribe to the
channel and check out some of my past
videos and I'll see you in the next
video